I know you said that numerous people
have reached out to you since our
interview about a year and a half ago
and I'd love to hear all of the emails
but one in particular that you were just
talking about reading beforehand was
about sort of the moral issue of
transmedia and I'm probably not saying
it correctly but what the email was
about sure this is the real common
question that I get from people is is
transmedia immoral and and it's kind of
you know first time someone asked me
that I thought it was it I didn't really
understand what they were saying and
like digging in with with with these
people to have those questions it's it
sort of rooted in is this just
capitalistic exploitation of the
audience is this manipulation of the
audience or you taking advantage of
people in a bad way and you know is this
just the is this just a big cash grab
that you don't really care about the
people you just care about taking their
money and there's all these issues that
that people have with it and my you know
my typical answer is that like anything
transmedia can be used in an immoral way
of course like it depends on who the
Creator is and it depends on what their
intentions are and what they're trying
to do are there people out there trying
to just use it as a cash grab are they
like just you know capitalistic jerks
that are just trying to take advantage
of opportunities and and of course just
just like regular film producers there
they're doing the same thing or
television producers or like morality
doesn't have anything to do with
platforms it's all about the intention
of the creator and the intention of the
business people that are trying to sort
of propagate this idea and this model
and whatever they're trying to do in the
venture so so is transmedia immoral per
se of course not you know I mean if my
my kitchen knife is an immoral per se if
I use my kitchen ice to stab you then
all of a sudden I've committed an
immoral thing with an with a you know a
morally neutral object right so a solid
depends on on the intention so I
I'm when it comes to like the capitalism
aspect of it like I am very passionate
that we were speaking about this before
I'm very passionate that that artists
don't have to be starving artists that
artists don't have to choose between
making money and and and doing their art
and that's usually people feel like it's
a binary choice people feel like I can
either sell out and and make money or I
can pursue my art which is somehow more
pure right and and really I think in
traditional entertainment that has been
the choice that people make is I can
either make studio movies or superhero
crap or I can do make the movies that I
love and and so you're either forced
into these one of these two options I
think in a 1i I'm not opposed to making
money I mean I'm very I'm very much a
capitalist I'm very much like I love the
fact that we live in America that allows
us to create an opportunity to be able
to maximize our brand and maximize
opportunities in a way that allows me to
feed my family and and have this be my
career I think that's awesome I what I
want for every screenwriter out there
every filmmaker out there every producer
every director is is I want them to be
able to do their dream has their career
I don't want them to work at Burger King
and make movies on the weekend like no
offense against Burger King I don't want
them to have to like work at Starbucks
or Hobby Lobby as they try to like have
a filmmaking be their side hustle like
if they're doing that that's awesome
that's what you have to do but
eventually what what my wish is for them
is is they get to a level where they can
just do filmmaking full-time and in
order to get there you either need to be
independently wealthy or you need to be
able to understand how to generate
revenue this is the entertainment is you
is is creating product that people will
purchase buy you know spend their money
on and if you don't make stuff that
people want to spend money on then
you're not going to be in business very
long no one's going to invest into your
stuff or no one's gonna come see it
there's there's no revenue flowing
therefore you're you can't make this
your business it's a very practical
question I don't think that's immoral to
say I want to be a career creator I want
to be I want filmmaking to be my career
in order to do that you have to figure
out how to make money now here's the
cool thing about transmedia this is why
I think transmedia is the opposite of
immoral really if you think about it in
that in the terms of capitalism if if if
let's say a filmmaker wants to make a
very non commercial art house film that
that you you know that this very
specific niche II that that breaks all
the conventions it's very like terrence
malick right
it's like terrence malick without
Terrence Malick's brand and so that's
probably not gonna get a wide
distribution it's probably not gonna get
picked up but this is this is the thing
that's in their heart that they want to
make so if that's all you have if that's
all you have then you're gonna have to
make the choice do I make this movie and
and have to do it on a small budget low
budget no budget and do it on the
weekends because nobody's going to
invest in it or it's not going to get
options not gonna picked up
I can either I could either make that
movie or I can change it to two then add
the 3x structure and they can read a
blake Schneider book and they can add
the save the cat stuff in it and make it
commercial and then all of a sudden now
I can sell it I can get the investment
except I get distribution for it etc etc
so both options I think are bad options
one option has you has you being a
starving artist which I think sucks
the other option has you selling your
soul in order and not do
the thing that's in your heart just in
order to be able to you know have this
be your full-time gig
that's the binary option now in a
transmedia model that option that binary
choice isn't the choice anymore now you
can say you know what I'm gonna do my
weird terrence malick art house film and
i'm going to do it as is now if you have
that as part of the bra of a broader IP
now all you have to say is if this thing
isn't gonna make money which it probably
won't what are the other things that I
can do to surround this film with that
will generate my revenue so if I can
point to now a novel or you know a
digital thing or you know a comic book
series or a mobile game or whatever it
is that you can surround this thing with
and these other things can generate
revenue now this weird arthouse thing
could almost be like a lost leader that
fuels the the the revenue and the
interest of these other things and so it
doesn't matter what the way the studio's
work is is they work with a resource
allocation model to where if they
release 14 movies in a year they know
that all 14 movies aren't going to be
solvent they're all not gonna make money
they they hope and pray out of the 14
movies they release a year that there's
four tentpoles that that that
overperformed to make up for the
deficits of the movies that financially
failed and they know that moving into
the year like every studio knows that
everything they're they're gonna do
isn't gonna be hit they they know that
most of the stuff is gonna make is gonna
lose money there's gonna be a few things
that make money those things uphold the
tint that's why they call them temples
so it's got a resource allocation model
if you take that same thinking and apply
that to a transmedia project and if you
say I know my art house movie is not
gonna make money that's totally fine you
still do that because that's what's in
your heart but now you just need
something else to over perform and make
enough money that
that it that it compensates for the
deficit created by the film because the
film cost money to make which means it's
going to technically that that one
element is going to lose money but as
long as you make that up somewhere else
now it's a net net gain and so and so
usually when I talk to to to indie
filmmakers that are very precious about
their one thing and they don't want to
change it because they don't wanna make
the binary choice they're less precious
about things and other platforms right
like they're fine with having a New York
Times bestselling novel and doing a very
commercialized novel they just don't
want to change their movie right they're
fine with having a very successful
mobile game like classic ant clans but
they just don't want to change their
movie and so and so all of a sudden for
the people that don't want to make the
binary choice the transmedia model is
the perfect thing for them because now
they can they can figure out how to
maintain the artistic integrity of the
one thing that they love while figuring
out how to drive revenue from other
places and with that you can still be
able to better position that for
investment I had a wonderful Maker that
was telling me he said he said I make
movies for me I don't care if anyone
likes them and I don't care if they make
money I make him I make it for me and
and I said I said that's great I said
you know what do you want to do I said I
want to be a career from filmmaker my
question is how are you gonna finance it
can you imagine going to an investor
interview and saying I want you to give
me a million dollars to make my movie
but I don't care if anyone likes it I
don't care if it makes money it's not
gonna happen it's just not gonna happen
and so but if you walk into the investor
and say listen my movie is gonna be
weird it's gonna be art house it's gonna
be niche I don't care if this makes
money but that's okay because I make it
money here here here here here and it's
all gonna work together right but my
movie the artistic integrity of my movie
is gonna be maintained that investor if
they're all if all the numbers line up
in the bottom line lines up
now you at least have a puncher's chance
for before you had zero chance so so all
of a sudden like you don't have to make
that choice which i think changes that
calculation a little bit about whether
this is a good thing or a bad thing
is this just commercialism gone awry or
is it actually a tool for independent
artists to be able to do the things that
they love for the rest of their life and
and that's that
I think shifting that thinking is is is
a big shift now the other thing about
this is that I think is really important
is is something that I call soapbox the
so a soapbox is basically a the theme
the message of your of your film like
where how do you how does your film how
does your script tap into like the
passion that's in your heart what are
you trying to say what what is your
commentary on the world how do you make
your your project feel not just cool but
important because it's tapped in to
something I think the greatest art from
throughout history comes from the
passion and perspective and the heart of
the creator I think you know things like
something like get out what they came
from like the heart of the crater and it
had an importance attached to it not
just a cool factor it wasn't just a cool
high concept it was it felt like an
important film because it was and I
think when you when you when you read
Hemingway or you listen to an Aretha
Franklin song there there's something
about the passion and the authenticity
about what these creators want to say
with her art that makes this art
sustainable and makes the art resonate
better with the audience I think
Tarantino every every every film that he
that that he makes is is just dripping
with his passion and you can see it and
it comes across in a very soulish
intangible way but the audience receives
it differently so if in today's world
it's important to do things and to
create things not just because they have
a you have a cool high concept idea it's
because you're actually passionate about
an issue passionate about something a
perspective something of importance that
gives your story a moral depth to it
that that is interesting now that could
be in something like you know something
like get out or something like Roma or
on the other end I think you know I
think George Lucas was saying something
very important and specific when he
created Star Wars he was supposed to
direct Apocalypse Now he before Francis
Ford Coppola because he was so
passionate about the Vietnam War the
movie got delayed so we wouldn't did
Star Wars instead which I think
ultimately was better for Apocalypse Now
but the but he took all all the passion
he had for imperialism and colonialism
and overreaching government and that
same passion that made him a hippie back
in the 60s as a college student he
poured that into like a larger IP
personally I don't think that black pen
black panther technically is one of the
best pictures as far as like the Oscar
conversation I don't think the the
technical aspect of black panther is
best picture worthy but Black Panther
had the technical had you know I think
solid superhero technicality they got
great costumes whole thing but black
panther was routed and tapped into an
importance that that elevates the film
above just being a normal superhero
movie it's important to people it's
important to culture and it connects to
people's hearts because of what it
stands for and so if if if if creators
understand what they want to say with
their art not just how to make money but
what they want to say what are you
trying to say as a person as a human
being what are you trying to convey like
they would like the world's on fire in a
thousand different ways and filmmakers
have an opportunity and to to to have a
platform to actually say something about
the world and in today's environment
that's actually wanted and desired by
the audience is this not an agenda and
the millennial generation they're not
like like my generation of my parents
generation where we just wanted popcorn
stuff they they want something real and
authentic and important and so I say all
this to say as a filmmaker if you have
something important to say
and if you put it in your movie and you
release your movie some people will hear
your message and there will be the
people that
watch a movie but in today's
oversaturated commoditized highly
competitive entertainment landscape not
everybody watches movies right what
about the the people that don't go to
the movies and all they do is listen to
music or play video games or what about
the people that don't watch TV or movies
at all just they play board games all
the time there's so much stuff that
people what about the kids that all they
do is they have their nose in the book
and they just read all the time do they
not need to hear your message as well if
they're so important to you if your
message is apps actually important if
you have commentary on on immigration
issues or racial issues or political
issues or not just any political
hot-button issues but if you're
passionate about anything then then
doesn't the person that's in the in the
basement playing board games don't they
need to hear that as well the kid that
just sits on their phone and plays
mobile games don't they need to hear
what you have to say as well of course
they do if your message is actually
important of course they do all of a
sudden in order to reach all those
people you have to diversify the way
that like you have to diversify your IP
because once you start looking at
transmedia less as a cash grab and more
as an opportunity to deploy your message
and your passion and your heart to
everybody doing everything around the
world all of a sudden makes a lot more
sense right now your IP is becoming all
things to all people
right and then being able to operate and
connect that message with everybody's
heart which then leads them back into a
community of people community of other
fans that all share that that that same
you know that same message and that's
what makes the that's what makes IP
important right so so talking about this
question the immorality I think again
goes back to the motivations but if your
motivation is I want to I want to change
the world in a positive way
I want to impact the world with this
very important thing that's coming out
of my soul then transmedia is the
perfect thing for you because now you're
getting to everybody that needs it and
not everybody does No
everybody does it no one does everything
but everybody does something if that
makes sense so there nobody like please
videogames watches movies listen to
music like nobody does everything
because there's so much stuff right but
everybody does something and in order to
reach everybody in this world now we
have to diversify the way we deploy the
message or deploy the passion and that's
where transmedia becomes beneficial
you